d'abord les gens matin donc j'ai pas
tant j'avoue qu'on aime ou hackers
latéraux régime
françois hollande hors course christiane
taubira selon sera t-elle dans la
primaire de la gauche ce vendredi soir
at même si la priorité de l'ancien garde
des sceaux semble être bel et bien sa
conférence une conférence au cours de
laquelle l'ex ministre milite pour une
réforme des institutions par une
réflexion citoyenne dans une démocratie
vraie démocratie il faut effectivement
que la parole citoyenne puisse s'élever
être prises en compte et je pense que
c'est un des grands enjeux de la
prochaine présidentielle
christiane taubira se verrait-elle un
jour présidente pour tenter de le savoir
je me suis fondu dans le public comment
est ce que vous avez manifesté votre
résistance et de combat salue l'homme
rien à côté de ce journaliste
douze mois qui n'obtiendra pas assorti
et puis se font dans le même lit pour
essayer de m'extorquer déclaration et
comme à france 3 bourgogne nous sommes
têtus nous avons tenté une troisième
approche vous ne souhaitez pas vous
présenter aux primaires de vous jeter
par la fenêtre je m'en charger
personnellement bon au vu des menaces je
préfère m'arrêter là l'ancienne garde
des sceaux a jusqu'au 15 décembre pour
déposer sa candidature ou pas
[Applaudissements]